hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm samantha
a chevelle we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a good kill the UK trailer
united kingdom it's an ethan hawke
january jones film yeah and that's all I
know eisani objective anytime day or
night drones are in the sky but whatever
God forsaken place where war with that
day due to your discretion to what good
kill the war is now a first person
shooter half of you were recruited
because you are a bunch of gamers light
above warheads on for so would you look
sick stores 200 combats believe that I
am a pilot and I'm not fine rifle when
ready this is the way damage that aboard
happens when he gets angry it's more
quiet I don't know what it is that I am
doing what it's not fine is that so bad
we're still making it safer
everything is for the Connecticut
Constance's somebody asked way around
someone asked me if it suggests war to
us that's just what you just got to
compartmentalize
camera cut for some reason I don't know
what happened but
I feel like that film could either be
really good or really bad yeah or it
could be like really good or really
cliche cuz I think it's an interesting
plot I haven't seen it done before like
that I mean it's a war movie but I
haven't seen it from the perspective of
like they have guys that are really good
at gaming better do ya doing piloting
without you know actually piloting
something and I think it's kind of
interesting to explore the concept of
how that makes one feel ya you know I
feel like if that is your passion that
would be difficult I mean if somebody
took my passion away from me and I was
just half acidly doing it part of the
experience of being a pilot is being a
pilot you know I don't actually get to
fly and you only get the bad side of it
yeah exactly which is to annihilate the
setup of it is interesting but as a
trailer progress i was like this kind of
seems like this my beginning a little
cliche to me yeah you know like the half
shadow and the cross on the wall and
raita like what was that the fence that
he was standing yeah I'm smoke yeah I
don't know that seems a little bit to it
the whole like throwing a glass and Nino
losing your temper by throwing a glass
at something it has moments where it
seems like that's why I mean it looks
like it could be powerful or it could be
really cliche I mean when it said the
producers of The Hurt Locker in dallas
buyers club I was like oh damn this is
gonna be depressing that was my first
thought I'm really good yeah depressing
but powerful that's what it's gonna be
the fact that they're producing it gives
me some faith in it yeah and the ethan
hawke is a really good actor and it
might just be the trailer and what
they're showing us because because a lot
of times when people compose trailers or
trying to make it look familiar because
they're like it worked before so if we
make it look like this but for all we
know might not turn out that way and add
your nickel he did lord of war this
Nicholas Cage mamita noxon it actually
three collaborating and I love lord of
war i think that's a fantastic film but
he's also done films like the host which
is not the greatest movie yeah i would
not have expected that see he did the
host and the host was like okay I mean
that's what I mean like the hose had is
kind of a similar thing like we're gonna
make this a powerful epic trailer yeah
and then the execution of it was like
this is cheesy and cliche I am worried
that this is going to meet cliche again
it could be the trailer mm-hmm but they
totally have the opportunity to do
something different in a war film that
we haven't seen but I'm getting the
feeling that third they're gonna try to
make it too familiar I mean it's a story
about a guy dealing with trauma and so
when they first said like he's quiet and
then they'd ask what happens when he
gets angry he gets more quiet and I
thought that was interesting because I'm
like huh I haven't actually heard that
line necessarily and what I think but
like I like seeing the internalized
destruction going on and I thought that
approaches more interesting but they
seem to be showing us the explosions of
this guy's in her tour moil I like more
of that like a cage man yeah exactly and
that's when start looking cliche to me
was the explosion areas of his emotions
not the explosions he is physically
causing on people in other countries
like in the trailer Ethan Hawke keeps
doing shots of like head down and Claire
it looks like he's trying to win an
Academy Award like overly dramatic yeah
and it it's I don't know like I the part
of me is like this looks like it could
be awesome and this other party is like
I'm kind of worried oh yeah I kind of
hope they release another trailer soon
so that we might be able to get a better
feel for what's going on I'm wondering
how much we really will feel for a
person cuz it sounds like he's affected
cuz he killed someone that he wasn't he
took a shot that he wasn't supposed to
take well I think in general he just
keeps taking shots that are killing
people he's really affected by this and
it looked like the trauma was dealing
more with him being like I want to be a
real pilot rather than dealing yea
rather than that because it seemed like
he just wanted to do that job but in
person yeah that's I don't know how much
I've really sympathize with this guy if
that's where the cases there were some
reviews on this trailer they were saying
how great it was and never heard of any
of those people but apparently in the
machine is good yeah thanks guys for
letting me know that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out Samantha Ashley Feld's
channel 2 if you want to know what's on
there just check it out
good stuff please shout outs are gonna
continue so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shout out through you earn
yourself a shot up I seen something
interesting yeah like samantha is a dead
hooker who has come back to life that
would be an interesting halloween
costume dead hooker come well that's
what you normally dress like some method
does this look done a hook great like it
looked like a hooker that was buried
Cuddy I don't know I didn't like what
you had to say so the camera cut out
okay and now it's over